governors have mandated generally not
all of them but most of them has said
there will be no elective surgeries
because we need to clear the hospitals
so that we can have beds and equipment
for for people with respiratory failure
because of kovat well the unintended
consequence of that is that cancer
patients are foregoing treatment and a
lot of hospitals are are on the verge of
bankruptcy because elective surgery was
a key part of their economic model so
they've made things worse by trying to
make things better hey I'm Dave Rubin
and according to the paperwork this is
still the Rubin report friendly reminder
everybody to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and click that pesky
notification bell joining me today is an
author a speaker and the host of Kibby
on Liberty on the blaze Matt kibbe
finally welcome to the Rubin report
finally hey Dave how's it going it's
going alright I have been on your show
several times and we we were overdue to
do it this way
flip the interviewer interviewee
situation every time I go on your show
we spend about 80% of it talking about
Star Wars and Liberty so I feel like
that's sort of where we have to start
here I'll just tell my audience right up
front you're a big Liberty guy for those
that don't know you you're a libertarian
you've worked for Rand Paul you run a
non-profit free the people that spreads
the ideas of liberty and freedom we're
gonna get far more into all of that
obviously related to coronavirus and
everything else but I feel that I have
to at least allow you to pontificate on
Star Wars and explain a little bit of
how Star Wars at least the prequels and
the originals do have a Liberty Flair
that a lot of people don't know about
you know per your recommendation I
actually went back after the last show
we did and I rewatched the prequels and
I'll probably get slaughtered for this
but I think you're right I think the
prequels may in fact be the most
relevant and and they may stand up to
the test of time I can count at least 25
30 governor's that want to be Palpatine
right now so we should probably all go
back and watch this and see exactly how
freedom dies - thunderous applause
because because I think we're living
this in real time and and all of these
things that that governors are doing
seemed like fundamentally
anti-democratic and it was all predicted
in the prequels it was all and Jar Jar
Binks who does that make Jar Jar Binks
in in a modern sense I don't know I even
I even dislike him less just like him
just like him less than I did before
which is shocking to me because I just I
I couldn't early on but I'm I'm even Pro
Jar Jar at this point yeah and probably
dislike him less than the way you
dislike some of the current governors
also I would imagine yeah I mean but
that's that's a low bar so I'm given Jar
Jar more than that okay so putting aside
Star Wars although maybe we can sort of
weave it back into this whole thing for
those that don't know you give me a
little bit of Matt kibbe 101 background
what what got you into the Liberty scene
in the first place
so I was my gateway drug to liberty was
actually an album by a band called Rush
it's called 2112 and you'll talk to a
number of libertarians particularly
libertarians my age will tell you this
story it was dedicated to the genius of
einer and I was 13 years old I had no
idea who that dude iron Rand was but she
had such an interesting name I went out
and stumbled across an old copy of her
novella anthem and I devoured it and I
followed the breadcrumbs and eventually
I Rand if you read her nonfiction stuff
she says to read the Austrian economists
and and specifically Ludwig von Mises so
I started reading all that stuff when I
was a kid and and if nothing else it was
the perfect way to never get a date
because I couldn't I couldn't get girls
that wanted to talk about Austrian
economics it's kind of strange that's
very bizarre maybe you're doing it wrong
somehow yeah maybe but what ended up
coming to the Deathstar the belly of the
beast Washington DC you go to graduate
school at George Mason University to
study economics and and eventually as it
always does politics sort of sucks you
in and I I have all sorts of horrible
things in my past I was I was the chief
economist for Lee Atwater at the
Republican National Committee I was
budget director at the US Chamber of
Commerce and eventually I went on to
found a tea party organization called
Freedom Works and that was ancient
history now but I went from economist to
political hack to grassroots organizer
and now hopefully communicator yeah what
what actually interests you more I guess
I guess economics fundamentally
interests you more than politics per se
because now we're very much in the same
space where we're sharing the ideas of
Liberty obviously but you have more of
sort of a schooling background in in
economics
yeah I mean the thing that I wanted to
do when I was a kid was right and I
spent a lot of time writing I was I was
one of those awkward libertarian kids so
you can imagine that anything that
doesn't involve societal interact
was pretty attractive to me and and I
wanted to be a writer and I started off
writing very academic stuff and you know
if you were lucky you could get ten
people to to read your peer reviewed
article with all the footnotes and and
all the fancy words that that we
academics like to use to pretend that we
know more than we do but I wrote my
first Wall Street Journal piece and I
just did the math and I realized you
know what if I could learn how to
communicate in plain English
I could probably reach a much broader
audience and and that's definitely what
we tried to do to do today we don't do a
lot of writing it free to people but we
use we use video storytelling to try to
sort of bridge the the language divide
between people that that would identify
with different political tribes because
because I do believe that Liberty is a
human value it's built into our systems
and and if we could figure out a way to
listen to people that are sort of
Liberty curious and and try to connect
with them I think that would that would
that would grow our community in a way
that just speaking economics will never
do yeah I should mention by the way
we've already been talking for a few
minutes and I did not point out that for
a libertarian you know you're dressed
fairly well you know you go to a
libertarian conference you got naked
people you got people with crazy shirts
look at you I mean you have a tie on
your jacket and shirt seemed to fit
appropriately are you sure you're
hanging with the right crew what's going
on over there oh this this is kind of a
forced quarantine counter-revolution
because I've I've worn all of my I've
worn all of my concert t-shirts and and
I haven't showered for days but I
decided that if I'm gonna start breaking
quarantine which is where I'm at now I
need to look good the problem is I still
don't have pants on so it's gonna it's
somehow it's probably gonna be awkward
if I go outside you and me both brother
you and me both but let's not this is a
family show so we'll leave it at that so
okay so I think having you on now is
sort of the perfect time because if
Liberty ever needed a jolt or if it ever
was about to have a resurgence I think
both of those things are sort of
possible right now I sense that we need
it more than ever at least in modern
times right now and that it could be on
the cusp
of really gaining momentum right now so
give me your basic breakdown of sort of
where we're at with Corona sort of what
you thought we should have done what was
the appropriate Liberty minded response
say two months ago in this first thing
was was rolling out to kind of where we
are right now
so my my initial reaction and I went
back and checked the first piece I wrote
about the pandemic was I think March
16th so so pretty early on I actually
wrote it on a beach and Joseph and Ike I
was on vacation and we had to cancel it
to get back to the United States before
I was afraid they were gonna close the
airports and and me being a geek I I
wrote this piece but I was worried that
that centralized top-down
one-size-fits-all solutions the very
complex problems was was inevitably
going to create a lot of unintended and
destructive consequences and I was
thinking about one of my economist
heroes Frederic Bastiat and and he he
talks about the seen and the unseen and
the inability of people to conceive of
the incredibly complex division of labor
that brings food to your table every day
you don't know how it happened and and
you can see that playing out now people
just assumed that food would show up and
so when when grocery store shelves are
empty
they start panicking and they frankly
they start blaming markets when in fact
it was meddling into the market process
that created that and so by not not even
conceiving that we would do these
massive never-ending lock downs the way
that that governors did I was worried
that were that the government was going
to do all sorts of things that would
make it more difficult to deal with not
just the disease and the virus but all
the other things we need to do to keep
our our families safe and and one of
those things is earn an income another
is put food on the table a third is is
actually being able to take care of
yourself and go outside maybe get cancer
treatments and all these things that
that are now proving impossible to do so
I knowing that government fails I was
afraid that they were gonna fail
philosophy bad and that's kind of where
we're at okay so I think most of my
audience will be with you on the okay we
don't like the the top-down version of
this we want to figure out sort of local
level individual stuff first what I see
a lot of people on the Twitter saying is
oh this
shows the flaw of libertarianism this
shows the flaw of small government
because in a time like this a pandemic
knows no borders
we need strong national decisions that
are across the board and the rest of it
how do you combat that concept well I
think the entire purpose of the market
process and I call it a mutual support
system the entire purpose of people
getting together and cooperating and
trading and engaging in ideas is is
because we live in a radically uncertain
world what happened yesterday is in no
way tells us what's going to happen
tomorrow and the whole point for that
process is for people to figure out
really complex things that are going to
happen to us and it feels like this
exogenously
exactly what you want a decentralized
system to solve and at top on that how
much government officials don't know we
always talk about market failure but we
never talk about government failure I
mean you could you could check some of
these boxes some of the horrific things
that federal and state governments have
done since the beginning of this
pandemic to screw up the food supply to
remember this this supposed cachet of
n95 masks oh yeah but yeah if I'm an
administration you're gonna have well
guess what government fails it always
fails because politics is a horrible way
to solve complex problems so when you
combine those two things if you're going
to shut off the the ingenuity of free
people to solve problems and replace it
with a central plan that is by
definition going to be dysfunctional and
wrong that's where you get really really
bad things in our society do you sense
that a lot of the divide on the people
that view the world top-down versus the
people that view the world bottom-up
that it's just a fundamental
psychological conditioning that they
have but it's not just oh we learned we
have different economic policies let's
say but that their fear centers are
different or you know I find when I when
I hear all the big government people
they they seem to have
this trust in a thing just because the
thing exists so it sort of inherently
must be good because it existed or maybe
50 years ago it was better or something
like that
versus I think people more in line with
our thinking where it's like well just
because it exists doesn't mean it's
inherently good so I want to just scale
the power back do you think that how
much a certain amount of this is just
your psychological makeup
you know it may be that and not to not
to sort of castigate my progressive
friends but but I think people don't
appreciate just how much we don't know
as individuals and how much our leaders
don't know even though they went to all
the right colleges and and have all of
these credentials and so maybe it's a
there's a line in the sand about
humility and being willing to say in
public what is this new pandemic and and
how does it compare to past pandemics
and what don't we know if some of these
modelers would have said you know what
there's no way that I could model this
in an honest way so let me tell you the
things that we do know but let me also
tell you that if I project numbers
there's no way it's gonna be right it's
always gonna be wrong and and that sort
of goes back to the old dream of a
progressivism that you could take
science and science was settled and
really smart people that went to the
right colleges could take that science
and impose it on the rest of us and we
would have this sort of rationally
planned top-down society but that lacks
humility it lacks any sense that that
you couldn't possibly know enough to
plan a complex economy and this was this
was rhetoric Hayek's entire critique of
of socialist planning and I think it
applies to to any would-be planner even
even some of the some of the governors
and how they're there they're telling us
all in a very microcosmic way like you
should do this and you shouldn't do that
yeah we talked about this a little bit
when I was on your show a couple weeks
ago but do you think some of this sort
of also is just the end of secularism in
a weird way it's the end of just oh
people just creating systems in the
moment that aren't necessarily experts
and that the experts get everything
wrong and that we just keep sort of
outsourcing all of our decision-making
and every day we wake up and as you're
saying yesterday doesn't doesn't really
form what tomorrow will be and that
we've just sort of hit the end of what
we can build in a weird way some
something like that
yeah like there's there's definitely
been this democratization and
decentralization disintermediation my
wife hates it when I use that word is it
it doesn't mean anything to anybody but
technology has has democratized
knowledge and information and I happen
to be one of those guys that was super
romantic about the potential to
decentralize everything based on that
but it seems like there's a backlash now
and and you have clickbait and you have
censorship and you have all these things
where sort of the the empire is breaking
back to get back to that face I knew
you'd get there do you get there the
experts do not like the fact that that
we probably don't need to go to school
to figure out electrical engineering we
probably don't need to defer to
epidemiologists because we could
actually do some of that research for
ourselves and discover that there is
patterns and there is history and and
all that stuff is available to us I
think in a lot of ways the backlash by
the planners is because we were we were
actually needing them less and they see
an opportunity right now to
reconsolidate power and take it back so
I'm very much along that that's what
this feels to me that they had almost
completely been decimated we've all sort
of woken up to the idea that you know
College a four-year college that you're
gonna spend a hundred twenty grand on is
it necessary and you know that all of
these giant institutions are failing and
we'll talk a little bit more about
journalism in just a sec so you really
think do you think though that this is
some sort of coordinated move then by
that establishment or those institutions
to do this I mean this is where we get
into like some strange conspiracy stuff
but these days anyone who's not a
conspiracy theorist isn't really
thinking you know when you're when
you're trapped in your house all day
though I don't believe in grand
conspiracies because of the natural
failures of governments and everything
else but you know you go back to Adam
Smith and he he I won't quote the quote
because I'll butcher it but the natural
tendency of business people and others
to conspire to hold up prices this is
part of human nature and and you don't
have to be a conspiracy theorist to
understand that the incentives aligned
with all of the people that are using
this crisis to to radically expand the
power of the state
you know the collusion and we've talked
about this before the collusion between
government experts and and social media
czars who are now deciding which
scientists we get to hear from which
economists which opinions and it's
gotten really absurd
I don't think that's a grand conspiracy
I just think their incentives a line and
they want control and they want control
the narrative they want control of the
market they want control of government
power whatever it is they're trying to
control this works perfectly because
people are nervous people are anxious
there's radical uncertainty right now
and people are exploiting it okay so
let's back up a little bit so with all
this in mind let's pretend kibby's
president it's 2020 america has some
sort of you know libertarian I don't
like to say you libertarian utopia
because I don't think libertarians
really believe in utopia in the way that
progressives tend to believe in it but
we have you know some sort of more
Liberty minded state may be that the
plan if the founders had planned and
you're president and you start getting
all these communication messages about
coronavirus is the first thing that you
do as a president to tell all of the
governor's you guys just handle this and
when you need help you call us but I'm
not gonna do anything with that
what about would that be the sort of
Liberty take on what the president
should be doing right now it would it
would definitely be federalism but but
to take it even a step further localism
and even individualism Iran famously
said that the most discriminated
minority is the individual and I think
that even at the local love
there can be tyranny if governments get
too full of themselves and in the key to
really complex problems things you don't
know anything about is tapping into
local knowledge and problem-solving and
this is what this is what governor's are
getting wrong so I don't think
federalism is is going to solve our
problem
you know that the libertarian joke is
that we're conspiring to take over the
government so that we'll leave you alone
that's that's I guess that would be my
mandate if I was president god help me
but the that the that it gets back to
the humility thing and you see this
playing out in very practical ways
governor's have mandated generally not
all of them but most of them has said
there will be no elective surgeries
because we need to clear the hospitals
so that we can have beds and equipment
for for people with respiratory failure
because of kovat well the unintended
consequence of that is that cancer
patients are foregoing treatment and a
lot of hospitals are are on the verge of
bankruptcy because elective surgery was
a key part of their economic model so
they've made things worse by trying to
make things better the only people that
would know for sure with the right
policy would be to make sure that a
hospital was safe in well-run and had
capacity would be to let doctors and
patients and hospital administrators in
that community figure that stuff out for
themselves that's got to be the way that
we get out of this mess now that we've
created it but that would be that would
be my take but but is the inherent
problem with that that the blue state
governors and and the lefties more
generally they don't view paying for
these things or hospitals having to you
know pay people or any of these things
as necessary it's sort of oh well do
whatever you're supposed to do as they
define it and then we'll just we'll pay
for it meaning we'll just magically make
up numbers so so logic is just sort of
coming against like a black hole in a
certain regard there's you know that I
think a lot of governors are suddenly
discovering that if they closed down all
the businesses there won't be any
revenue to pay that all of it's
incredible and now they're of course
going to the federal government begging
for a bill out there and I hope I hope
we don't give it to them because that'll
just reward really bad behavior but
there is like a shocking naivete about
and I said this earlier hot is food get
on the table but but where does where
does all that revenue come from that
funds all of these programs how do
hospitals
stay in business it's it's very much a
market that allows for that where you
have customers and you have people
selling services and you know for some
reason we don't think that that's
appropriate in health care but it's
essential if you actually want access to
a doctor when when you're diagnosed with
cancer and no amount of empty government
promises are a substitute for that and
we're gonna learn this right now all of
these generous unemployment benefits all
of people that are on Medicaid and
Medicare these programs are gonna get
squeezed like never before because
there's just gonna be a total collapse
in government revenue and they're hoping
that the feds bail them out but the feds
don't have any money either so we're
gonna we're gonna print it and there's
all sorts of like this would be a
different program about what's gonna
happen when all that stuff happens but
everyone thinks that that resources are
just like this exhausting out there then
magic is there and all we got to do is
read avoid it you know it's gonna
disappear and then we're gonna discover
what that that sort of social justice
model is gonna lead to and it's it's
gonna make everybody less safe everybody
less healthy everybody more hungry and
and I hope there's some ownership of
that but we'll see so going on the
assumption there is in ownership of that
because that doesn't seem to be how
inertia works or there or there might at
least be states that that sort of own it
themselves so you know Florida and Texas
for example with zero state income tax
are doing nice jobs balancing their
budgets and I do sense there there's
sort of a
idea floating around the internet right
now that in effect what New York and
California particularly are doing is
they're trying to absolutely tank their
own economies because they're they're so
screwed and I say this as someone that
grew up in New York and now lives in
California that they have so screwed
themselves despite the 13 percent income
tax that I pay here in California on top
of LA you know city tax that they have
no way of getting out so it's like
destroyed let's let's blow up the whole
thing knowing the feds will have to come
in and clean up the mess I know you're
not for that but do you think that
that's actually possible that that's
really what they're like newsome's
really sitting around going we're
looking at the numbers there's no way
out of this and let's just blow up the
whole damn thing and force it we'll
stick it to trump something like that
yeah I mean I think it's I think it's
it's clearly part of their strategy they
they don't have any they don't seem to
have any concern about actually cleaning
up their own house so they're they're
gonna look for that bailout but let me
we talked about conspiracy theories let
me take it a step further yeah James
james Clyburn who is Nancy Pelosi is
number three in the house in early March
when they were debating that first
trillion dollar bill which turned into a
two point two trillion dollar bill he
said to his colleagues this is an
opportunity to remake America the way
that we want to see it happen and I
think there's a method to this madness
when you give people such extravagant
stravagant unemployment benefits that
employers can't hire them back because
they're making a ton more money being
unemployed that sounds like something
that a AOC would love to see because she
she told us all not to go back to our
jobs yeah she does there's no value in
work basically yeah and and we all know
that that's economically ignorant but
but what if this is a process to
radically expand the welfare state I
give you if you're putting a third of
Americans out of work and you're giving
them these generous benefits at what
point is any Republican or Democrat
going to roll that back they never they
never get rolled back
temporary poke programs become permanent
but you know the other piece of this
which I think is even more ominous is
this this tracking system that they're
developing where if you if you do decide
to go to a restaurant there's gonna be
some government bureaucrat there wanting
your information so that they can get in
contact with you later that sounds like
something the Communist Chinese would do
well you know if we want to do the
conspiracy thing then it's like wow
maybe China unleash this knowing all
these stupid things that we would then
do to ourselves well it's it is sort of
I I don't know if they did it on purpose
but if we do adopt the Chinese model
based on on by the way huge government
failures that originated in China one
government failure after another and all
the sudden we're like let's be like
China then then America is done like
we're we're just done if we're not gonna
push back but but to your point like the
only way that the governor of California
and the governor of New York are held
accountable is if the people do it and
it's got to be bottom-up the same logic
that applies to markets applies to
political pressure and I'm not talking
about voting I'm talking about the
people that drive public opinion that
actually shape what politicians will do
tomorrow that's where this revolution
has to start it's got to be peaceful
it's got to be civilly disobedience and
you're seeing it in in the streets and
on the beaches today people are like
we're done you guys lied to us you told
us that we were flattening the curve and
now you won't let us out of our houses
we're just done
alright Kibby so that I want some advice
as a guy that lives in California I mean
I've been I've been tweeting about this
and Fox News ran ran a Chiron I didn't
realize they were good knew when I was
on Dana Perino
that said Dave Rubin is considering
leaving California because of a tweet
but I do sense that the rubber is
meeting the road with my ideas I believe
in federalism I believe in all the
things you're talking about on states
rights and the foot vote and all of
those things do you think it's worth it
in a place like California for liberty
minded people and let's say
right-leaning people whatever that is to
stay in fight or
is this thing too far gone what do you
actually think
um I I think there's a very strong
argument for for fleeing these states
that are so authoritarian and by the way
I should I should own up the fact I live
in the District of Columbia and my mayor
is every bit as authoritarian as your
governor
um we're locked down until June is well
here and she's not releasing the data at
the modeling Mogae she says she has it
but she won't tell us what it is so I'm
in the same boat as you I'm living
literally in the belly of the beast I'm
two blocks from the Capitol right now
and I've been trying to convince my wife
to let me flee to a red state I actually
think there's going to be a political
realignment that's not so much red
versus blue it's gonna be governors that
have the humility to let free people
rebuild the mess that our governments
have made and people are gonna vote with
their feets this is why we like
federalism because there there is
competition between states
I think Texans are a little worried that
too many of you California and and break
everything that they've done well that's
where everybody you know people in
Colorado are worried about that people
in Arizona are worried about that that
seems to happen
Californians raise taxes on themselves
the state crumbles and then they export
these idiotic ideas I'm almost I'd
almost be for Texas having some sort of
test to get in I know they can't really
do that but like some sort of like you
can't come here to suddenly institute a
state income tax or something like that
but but alright so with that in mind
though for people that believe in
federalism that believe that the way we
set this thing up was right if what
you're saying is right and I've been
thinking about this a lot it's almost
like not to say we're gonna end up in a
civil war but but we are gonna then have
to actually watch States fail but that's
an almost unimaginable idea for a lot of
people don't you think
it's I mean it's gonna be very difficult
I I could count on one and maybe two
hands the the number of Republicans that
I think have sort of the testicular
fortitude to say no to bailing out
California and you know who those guys
are
and there aren't very many others that
are willing to do that and and so much
about politics is is driven by their
fear of not getting reelected their fear
that someone's gonna call them a bad
person because they didn't do that but
if you actually want federalism to work
you can't bail out states that have
behaved so badly you know California was
broke long before this pandemic and
everything they've done since then has
only exacerbated their ability to grow
their way out of it once once we get
past the pandemic it's got to be held
accountable and this gets back to this
political realignment that I'm thinking
about I was uh you know this I was a tea
party organizer in 2008 when Nancy
Pelosi and John Boehner walked down the
aisle of the House floor and said we
must bail out Wall Street together and
the American people rose up because they
had access to information online that to
me was the day that I think the tea
party was born in opposition to the Wall
Street bailouts and and by the way in
the beginning it wasn't a partisan thing
at all Occupy Wall Street had same some
of the same predilections and some of
the revolts against the in justices of
that I think the lockdowns are that same
seismic shock on our political
alignments and we'll see where the chips
fall but I think there's an opportunity
out of this disaster to get people to
pay a little more attention to what the
government's doing to them it's
interesting because as you're saying
that you'd love to convince your wife to
get moving and you know we're having
those same discussions here I'm kind of
with you on what you just said there
which is maybe this is the shock maybe
the average Californian is gonna go whoa
this just does not make sense what have
we done now that's putting maybe a
little too much faith in people waking
up but that's the part of me that wants
to stay and fight because I do love it
here that's the part that's like all
right dig in
you know we try it for like two three
more years to see if in the aftermath
this thing can rebuild pop properly I
don't know that it's possible you know
that's maybe that's a little too you
know rose-colored glasses or something
I'm a I'm a libertarian that has been
most of my career in Washington DC so
I'm a perfectly building they chase
impossible rainbows yeah if if the
states actually do go these these
separate ways do you think we have
enough of a national ethos anymore to
keep us together as a nation
because it seems like the next step down
there down the road with this right yeah
it's it is it's become increasingly
worrisome that the way that this tribal
divide and how everything is political
now and and it's always red versus blue
even for most of us who don't even
identify with either one of those tribes
and and the the the authoritarian left
is so pushed a libertarian like me away
from it we're all looking for a home and
I I still think that classical
liberalism or libertarianism or humility
call it just call it the kind of
humility that your mom tried to teach
you that to me is the only thing that
holds us together because if we're going
to use the reins of power at the state
level at the federal level to force
everybody to live just the way that we
believe they should live I don't see how
that doesn't get violent at some point
because the alternative has to be
peaceful cooperation tolerance you live
your life exactly how you want as long
as you don't hurt me or take my stuff
there is a solution here and that
solution by the way was very much built
into the American blueprint with the
Declaration of Independence and the Bill
of Rights in the Constitution so we're
gonna have to revisit that and and yeah
I get getting back to this this
counter-revolution that we hope will
happen it's got to start there because
that is the only solution that keeps us
together yeah because I could also see a
situation where the red state people so
now you're in Texas you know you have
your no state income tax you still have
federal income tax but you're going wait
a minute why am i paying all this money
to the Fed to bail out the guys that who
screwed up the whole thing so I could
see an average Texan who's living their
life doing everything properly following
the law voting in the right type of
people becoming seriously resentful of
people in another state and that that's
deeply dangerous
you mentioned classical liberalism of
course so I have to ask you the question
that every single interviewer I think
asked me on my book tour which is do you
see any meaningful distinction between
classical liberalism
and libertarianism does it does it even
matter or is this just for the Waukee
guys to sit around after libertarian
conferences have a drink and Whittle it
away well of course there's only one
perfect libertarian and that's me and
everybody else that's a libertarian joke
but because we spent so much time
arguing about the the malucia so I I
actually don't think there's a
difference and and I I would I could
depending on on who I'm trying to speak
to and I don't think there's any
contradiction in this I either use the
word libertarian which Hayek says is a
made-up word he he likes the word
liberal but now we have to qualify it by
saying classical liberals so that people
appreciate that it's different than than
how it might be used today but but I
think constitutional conservative is
kind of the same thing because we all
may have personal preferences and
lifestyle choices that that we make that
are different but in terms of governance
and how we cooperate with each other
it's the same philosophy it's all about
that that localism that bottom-up
there's a couple rules don't hurt people
don't take their stuff other than that
we we all get along and if you want to
go to church go to church if you don't
want to go to church don't go to church
I don't really care because I'm minding
enough of my own business the way my mom
taught me to ya know I'm with you on
that so let me ask you one or two sort
of the core libertarian things where are
you at with open borders this is one of
the ones where when I talk to the more
libertarian minded people like I am
completely not an open borders guy I get
some of the arguments I'd be happy for
you to lay out some of the arguments if
you are but this is one of the ones
where I think especially now I think the
more nationalists and I don't mean
nationalists in a scary word
nationalists I believe we're Nations and
we can set our own borders and things
like that
I think I think Trump has some wins on
that coming in the election because of
coronavirus our ability to control our
own borders but I know a lot of
libertarians don't like that they want
free trade free complete ability to
bounce across everywhere all the time
where you add on that
so I used to be for open borders but now
I've sort of changed my position because
I do think we need to build a wall
between California and America because
but you know I used to I said III have a
more libertarian view on you than this
and I I used to give speeches but we
party audiences I talk to progressive
audiences and my view is the same if you
want to come to this country and work
and follow the rules we want you and I
don't think you need to build a wall to
enforce a rule like that what you need
to do is get politics out of the process
of getting the people here that want to
work and want to follow the rules
because because right now the the system
is gamed there are there are some
Republicans that don't want any
immigration there are some Democrats
that don't want any immigration because
it undermines union power and there are
other Democrats that once people get
here illegally they want to sort of own
and control them so the whole thing's
super political and I think the answers
got to be a a simplification of the
process so that if guest workers won't
want to come and they want to follow the
rules and they they want to and or if
they they want to become a citizen and
be an American I think those processes
should be predictable and unpolitical
and I think if you did those things you
could focus border security on on
violent gangs that that are running
drugs across the Mexican border
you could repeal a drug war which would
also get rid of the tech gangs there's
all sorts of free-market things you
could do that I think would solve some
of the concerns that conservatives have
about border security without building
walls so so I am more libertarian on
that but I don't I don't think it's
unreasonable because of so many of the
things that do make America great come
from immigrants that came to this
country and added value and built this
beautiful quilt that that is America so
I I don't want to shut that down yeah it
actually doesn't sound like we're very
far off on that I always say I'm not I'm
not sort of for a wall
against the wall if you told me there
were certain parts of the border that we
could prove a wall would be particularly
effective and there have been some
places like that then I'm okay with that
but I don't like the idea of you know
the three thousand mile wall just so
that we have this this idea of
protection when in many ways we're not
going to be doing that and then you know
I'm sort of well where you add on like
pathway to citizenship for for the
twelve million or so people that are
here what do you do you put them back at
the back of the line or how do we even
get these guys to come out of the
shadows and the rest of it yeah I mean I
think I would I would be for a pathway
of citizenship and it's easy to say that
and I think politics would screw it up
but I think a better way to solve that
problem is that a lot of people that
came here illegally probably would
prefer a reliable guest worker program
so that they could go back home and be
with their families I have I have lots
of friends in the free market community
in Latin America in Honduras for
instance and and I hear the story again
and again and again that the reason that
people are are illegal in the United
States is that they don't have the
confidence that they could come and go
with that season's say they're picking
crops or whatever they're doing they
can't do that so I feel like the path to
citizenship thing is almost a changing
of the conversation because we're
primarily talking about people that just
want to do work that's actually
available to them and they're doing it
because their economies are so screwed
up in Honduras but the American drug war
has given all the power to the drug gang
so families are making that march
because they're desperate it's not a
choice they would make so again I think
there's a there's probably a freedom
based solution that doesn't reward
illegal behavior but would would get
people to voluntarily go back if there
was a predictable process by which they
could come back and forth based on
employment opportunities so where are
you generally at with Trump well I think
that I think the name Trump was only
mentioned once in this entire interview
just a moment ago I sense with most
libertarians they kinda like a lot of
the stuff Trump is
regulation cut taxes we don't seem to be
going to extra Wars if anything we're
trying to get out of Afghanistan now and
we're not gonna be nation-building
that's all very libertarian stuff I
think a lot of libertarians and and I
one night we were at a I think it was a
Yale conference and we had a table of
libertarians and it seemed very obvious
to me that everyone's sort of like the
things he was doing but just had a
personal they just don't like him
personally like it was bad idea and I
sense that a lot of people have that
thing is that kind of where you are what
do you make of this whole thing with
Trump Trump and the liberty minded
people cuz obviously he's not his core
is not a Liberty might at core he would
love to take more power if he could but
yet it seems like he's doing a pretty
decent job you know he has he does have
a sort of an authoritarian mindset and
and I'm I'm not even convinced he's ever
read the Bill of Rights so I guess I
guess that's an excuse but full
disclosure and you mentioned this I I
did I did work for a Rand Paul super
back when he was running for president
and then I ran a Gary Johnson super PAC
after that so as a candidate I was a
never Trump er because I had a candidate
and at what his name wasn't Trump as
president it's a totally different thing
and I'll go back to when Barack Obama
was president I spent a lot of my time
organizing the the Tea Party and
opposing the stimulus and the bailouts
and Obamacare and all that stuff but
when he want to do criminal justice
reform I went to the Justice Department
and worked with Eric Holder and hopes to
get something done my attitude or Trump
is kind of the same way when he's good
I'm I want to work with him I've done
lots of shows supporting him on things
like criminal justice reform staying out
of of so many permanent wars and and
stuff like that that he's done but on
other things that that libertarians care
a bunch about you know we just had a
vote on on surveillance power and
whether or not the deep state would get
more power
Trump's been horrible on that and I
don't know if it's bad advisers or what
if you care about dad
and spending Trump's been horrible on
that so it's a mixed bag but but our job
when we have a president is to make them
better and so I don't spend all my time
railing about Trump I'm hoping that he
will he will do some of the things that
that would make more sense and I was
hopeful before instance that that he
would be a strong voice on reopening the
economy but he's been a little hard to
understand on this he peaked he spent a
lot of time picking on the governor of
Georgia Kemp who who was one of the
first to unlock down their economy so
even on that it's it's a mixed bag with
Trump but you know I'm I'm a libertarian
I don't really get on board with with
big government whether it's Republican
or Democrat you mean you don't think
Trump can solve all of your personal
problems is that what you're telling me
I can't want to live in a world where I
don't have to worry who the president is
that's how naive I am like if if you had
a president they actually would you mad
yeah
um all right so let's let's move off
Trump you mentioned Rand Paul and since
you did work with him for a little bit I
had him on last week and one of the
things that I said to him was sort of
exactly what you just laid out there
about Trump which is that one of the
reasons I'm more okay now with Trump is
that Rand Paul has become one of his
biggest allies and it's interesting
because Paul's explanation of why he's
ok with Trump is sort of what you just
said that yeah there's good there's bad
but I can try to push him the best I can
on the good stuff
and the rest of it so in a weird way it
almost seems to me that that's the best
libertarians can do we're not
particularly good at getting candidates
out there
the you know the party's just an
absolute disaster you want to explain a
little bit about why the party seems to
be such a disaster even though so many
of the ideas if you could get people to
listen to them they are right and again
maybe sort of getting us back to the
beginning maybe they are about to have a
real moment yeah so like personally just
point out that both Rand Paul and Mike
Lee are in highly leveraged position in
the Senate and they they on any given
vote they could be the difference
between passing and not passing and I
think they both both done a very good
job you know neither one of them
obviously Rand Paul ran against Trump
and Mike Lee supported Ted Cruz in the
primaries but but they've sort of
stepped up and said mr. president I'm
gonna work with you on the things that
we share in common and I'm gonna try to
convince you on some other things and I
think that's a really smart thing to do
and libertarians had criticized that I
don't really understand because the
point is is to get the right policy the
points not to sort of virtually signal
debt that trumps an awful guy and but
for the for the libertarian party and
third parties generally I think that
there is inevitably a moment where the
two-party duopoly does break up and and
the the reason I think that the
Libertarian Party has struggled so much
is that it is the two parties that set
the rules by which political parties
operates and and in Gary Johnson was a
great example of that they kept changing
the rules of how you got on to the
presidential stage by any historical
measure Gary Johnson would have been on
that
stage but they keep changing the rules
and that makes it very difficult for
parties to compete because if you're
raising money for politics they devalue
pitch that you make to donors is we can
win this race for a third party and not
just libertarians but but greens or
constitutionalists or whatever the two
parties that control all the power make
it virtually impossible for them to
compete and it's usually some accident
like say Abraham Lincoln that that
creates a new third party it's gonna
happen but it's it's kind of a chicken
and egg thing the libertarian party
would would have ballot access in all 50
states would have a better donor base
would have would attract more talent if
they were allowed to compete and I don't
know how that breaks through they got to
break through somehow yeah so you're
saying it's not the naked guy running on
stage that's gonna break through is that
what you're saying so when I was oh when
I was raising money for Gary Johnson
I had brought on some Republican donors
major guys that were finally paying
attention to the Libertarian Party and
they tuned in to that convention on
c-span and the first thing they saw was
a fat hairy naked guy and they're like
yeah thanks there's other personas and
my money
yeah that of course that was before
imposed lock downs where none of us are
really wearing pence anymore exactly
there you go so all right so to just
sort of bring this full circle then so
with all of these ideas and with us
still in these rolling lockouts UND see
me in California
we're watching Texas in Florida are you
worried that that the biggest disaster
looming actually sort of directly
coronavirus related is that if there's
suddenly a bump let's say in two weeks
in texas or Florida which in a weird way
it almost feels inevitably will have to
happen because that's that's sort of the
risk that they're playing with that the
media will use that as such a freaking
hammer to prove that they should have
never opened up that it basically puts
DC New York and California in perpetual
lockdown and then it actually scares I'm
doing the reverse of the silver lining
thing now it actually scares the people
who have been fighting for their freedom
enough to shut up and then next thing
you know Texas and Florida are back in a
lockdown yeah I think it's a real risk
you know historically and I'm I'm not an
epidemiologist but I've read so much we
all have just trying to figure out what
the hell's going on and in the during
the Hong Kong flu there was very much a
peak in the winter of 68 and a second
peak in the winter of 69 in the summer
things settled down a little bit in in
that particular one the peak wasn't in
the same places so San Francisco was a
hotbed in the first peak of the Hong
Kong flu so so how this plays out I
don't know but but I look at the same
data that that people on the other side
are looking at I look at what's going on
in Sweden I look at what's going on in
New York and other places and the way
that people manipulate data to tell
their story is is deeply frustrating to
me so yes we we might have a beautiful
revolution that discovers humility and
and localism and and in American freedom
again or this could be the cudgel that
that big government types used to
permanently imp
man's social tracing to permanently
implement a massive welfare state were
where most Americans don't work anymore
to permanently implement government-run
health care all of these things that
they've wanted to do they're trying to
do it now and if they're gonna keep
demonizing they're gonna keep
demagoguing and the media's gonna keep
helping them so we're gonna have to
create that alternative narrative and
pretty much no matter what happens with
the virus all right so we started at
Star Wars we're ending in dystopian
future so let's add a little more
dystopia to it then I will see if maybe
we can end this on a positive note
what big tech just talk to me about your
feelings we've talked about it a whole
bunch I do not want government
regulating this I think if you have one
huge problem and another huge problem
then you combine them into the Voltron
of problems that is not good do you
think there is a way we can survive this
technological adolescence where we've
already all conceded all of our
information we have no idea how we're
being manipulated with algorithms and
shadow banning and the rest of it has
the ship just totally sailed do you
think that competition can can fix any
of this we're yet we we talked about
this last time and the way that YouTube
is essentially doing the bidding of
International Health Organization's when
they decide what is true and false is a
new level of dystopian 1984 spout creepy
and and I think they're gonna pay a
price for that the alternative is people
seeing that happen and seeing videos
that are banned or for noting that it's
even slightly controversial just having
a different opinion about something I
think there's gonna be a lot of other
platforms and and I'm seeing people are
now posting those same videos on their
web sites I can tell you free to
people's websites and all of our videos
it's gone up 82% in the last month or so
and I think that's probably natural
because people are bidding off of those
those dictated censored platforms and
moving to other things and and and you
know you're you're going
have to do that too because ultimately
they're gonna kick us all off and we're
just gonna have to prepare for that day
[Music]
felt good and then right at the end then
the prepare part got depressing again
give me some libertarian hope here Kimi
to take us out come on man
markets markets work and and I'm old
enough to remember and we've had this
argument over over drinks I'm old enough
to remember when we're all scared to
death that that Microsoft and and
Windows was going to be this is forever
dominant thing and it just wasn't true
it's never true and I think even with
the collusion between big corporations
and big governments there's always an
innovation there's always a disruption I
have a lot of faith in entrepreneurship
and I think that despite what the
government does the human spirit always
rises above that I think it's gonna be
beautiful
I've always believed that the future is
beautiful and I think that markets have
always cleaned up the mess after
governments have destroyed lives and and
disrupted businesses and and broken
people's wills everything that we're
seeing happening today people have risen
up to to much bigger challenges than
that I'm thinking about you know what
Mao did the Chinese people and what Hugo
Chavez and Nicolas Maduro did did a
Venezuelan people people can not be
stopped freedom cannot be stopped
there's your optimism yeah you did it
can be all right
well everyone can watch Kibby on liberty
on blaze TV and i look forward to seeing
you in person probably around 2024 so
well we'll get permission from somebody
hey thank you my friend
thank you sir if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell